in 3 2 1 go welcome to the three and a
half minute talk show here's your host
Kate Peter man nice thank you guys for
being here welcome to the three and a
half minute talk show I am your host
Kate Peterman we try to fill three and a
half minutes with an entire talk show
will we do it I don't know but I brushed
my hair for it huh glad to be here very
glad to be here it's a great time of
year holidays coming up very magic so
excited assistive the only thing I don't
like is that you know gas prices go up
and plane tickets go up and you know
sometimes you try to be a little bit
more frugal so if you're looking for a
cheap travel alternative might I suggest
my cousin Kevin's van an enticing offer
absolutely
he seems filled with the Christmas
spirit he's filled with something am i
right anyway so the other day I was
walking to the grocery okay well stick
around we got a great show coming for
you today
so and Ryan do it I'm doing Fanta
they're gonna have time for the rest of
it all right
she's she used to be here at BuzzFeed
and now she's writing for a show called
good trouble coming to freeform this
January give it up for Ashley Perez
absolutely amazing job thanks so much
absolutely I'm so excited for you to be
my first guest Oh I'm the first guys yes
yeah I've just I couldn't think of
anyone better after you here you are so
I heard you're having a bit of trouble
with your cat yes James yes tabby you
like takes a lot of energy and it was
Christmas and we put up all the Ashleigh
Perez ladies and gentlemen next up we
have someone a little unconventional
coven TIA
please give it up for Tim from critter
squad
boy and Tim who do we have here this is
Rosco our black roughneck monitor and
why is his tongue split like that oh
that's a great question so many lizards
and snakes species have a split tongue
in order to taste the air and they're
actually locate their food I feel like I
do that with my regular tongue yeah I
got good taste there and locate the food
I mean that's all I've been eating now
does he does he bite he definitely can
bite yes how's it hurt you been bitten
by him I have not no you didn't do
anything to make him mad no not yet why
is he shedding no he's shedding because
he is a growing boy so reptiles they'll
constantly grow who's monitoring the
other lizards monitor I barely know her
anyway up next we got the musical
stylings of the band Queen what their
song mojo sex in America
everything was in order to over
limitless desire like a freedom
Oh